To visit all elements in a Two-D array, you want to loop over the rows and
columns. Let's first loop over the rows. So we have a row index i that assumes
to values zero, one, and two in this example. Similarly, we'll have a column
index j, then in this example, we'll go from zero to one. If we had more
columns, of course it would go further. When you have a row of column index,
then we can access the element at the i-th row, and the j-th column. So what
you see over here. As the general expression for an element at an arbitrary row
and arbitrary column. In this case, we just print it and we use printf. So that
the print out lines up nicely. So we would now print this element and print
that element, that would finish the innerloop. Then the outer loop would pick
the next row, we print these two, and then the outer loop picks the last row.
And we print those two. Now, of course, we want the numbers to line up nicely,
so after printing each row, we want to print a new line. Notice that this
statement is contained in the outer loop, because it happens once per row. But
its not in the inner loop because we don't want a new line after every of the
element. Now, let's look at the missing balance here. Of course, in this simple
example I could just say I should be less than three, J should be less than
two, but in general, someone might just hand you a two-dimensional array and
you should ask it how big it is. Just like with a one-dimensional array, you
just use the length field to find out how big an array is. You can get the
number of rows from a two-dimensional array by asking it arrayname.length. And
the reason for this is that a two-dimensional array is actually an array of
one-dimensional arrays. So prices, which looks like this nice tabular
arrangement, really is an array of three arrays, one for each row. And so the
number of rows is given by that length. Now, we need to look at how many
columns we have. Here you have a row. And the length of that row is the number
of columns. So in general, you should remember that, for any two-dimensional
array, you get the number of rows with this expression, the number of columns
with that expression. Now, let's move on to doing something more interesting
with two-dimensional arrays and gas prices.